in this video we'll talk about the
process of gastrulation in frogs
especially we would look at the
morphogenetic movements during the Frog
gastrulation
so what really happens during the Frog
gastrulation during gastrulation the
cells of blastula are given new
positions they got new neighbors and
they form a multicellular body plan now
this is a common theme in any kind of
gastrulation where one layer of cells
eventually give rise give rise to
multiple layers which forms ectoderm
mesoderm and endoderm
now there are characteristic
morphogenetic movements which we have
discussed in earlier videos like
invagination ingression involution
delamination and Epi bully all of these
morphogenetic movements are really
essential during gastrulation these are
common themes if you want to learn
details about these click on the video
in the I button but in this video we
would try to appreciate where and when
these kind of basic morphogenetic
movement happens during the Frog
gastrulation
so if we cut a long story short this is
how the Frog gastrulation would look
like
in this particular diagram
the red represents ectoderm blue
represents mesoderm and yellow
represents endoderm
so during the process of frog
gastrulation
first
the goal is to bring the
endodermal organs or the cells that give
rise to endoderm inside of the embryo
which is currently outside in the
Blastoise blastocyst stage
now then we have to surround the
embryo with a sheath of ectoderm and
finally the challenges took place the
mesoderm cells in between the ectoderm
and endoderm so overall this tells us
that there is a reorganization of these
germ layers during the process of
gastrulation so obviously we have to
appreciate the morphogenetic movement
that give rise to this kind of
reorganization
so this is the starting point you can
see this particular blastula of the
xenopus the vegetal pole and the animal
pole is depicted like this and the
cavity is known as blastocele
so each three color represent different
layers mesoderm ectoderm and endoderm
which are different defined earlier
now first of all there are cells known
as bottle cells and these cells
invaginate
through the blastopore
so the first movement that happens
during the process of frog gastrulation
is invagination
so these bottle cells has ah
kind of like bottle-like neck that
protrudes towards the surface
and these bottle cells are really
important to understand the overall
process of gastrulation the bottle cells
move inside and forms a narrow
canal-like situation
anyway in this particular diagram you
can appreciate how the ectoderm is shown
here then the mesoderm can further be
divided into
so both of these form together the
involuting marginal Zone because the
second movement we are talking about is
the involution
remember involution means sliding one
sheet of cells below the another
so Follow the arrow to understand how
these cells of misoderm would eventually
involute
and grow slowly just beneath the
ectodermal layer so let us follow the
movement of these blue cells
while these blue cells are moving
beneath the red cells the red cells are
undergoing the process of Epi bully API
bully is a movement by which the entire
embryo would be surrounded by these
ectodermal cells so two simultaneous
movement is going on Whose result is
somewhat like this so again we can see
the dorsal lip here
this Arrow suggests the direction of
involution movement of the mesoderm
tissue or imz tissue and the outer Arrow
shows the direction of AP Boolean so
involution and AP bully are two
important movement that are happening
during the frog gastrulation epiboli is
occurring in the ectodermal cells and
imz or the mesodermal cells are actually
involuting
so these are two appreciable
morphogenetic movements that are nicely
trackable if one put a dye in these path
of these moving cells eventually one can
track the movement by tracking the dye
so overall we learned how uh different
layers get arranged during the formation
of frog
gastrula and you can see the internal
dark yellow cavity that is known as
arkentiron because Blaster seal is now
kind of shrunken and it is removed now
arkant Iran is the new cavity which is
surrounded by the endoderm and
archenteron is the Primitive gut
eventually it would give rise to the
alimentary canal of these tadpoles
so overall we looked at the process of
um
gastrulation we appreciated the
movements like AP bully and we
appreciated the movements like
involution that happens during this
process so I hope this was short and
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe please follow us on
Instagram and Facebook support our
Channel using super thanks see you in
next video